Hi. I'm Dave Duggal,
the founder and CEO
of Enterprise Web.
I'm glad to be here with you
today at CDW twenty one,
to present my talk,
One Graph to Bind Them All,
Thinking Data and
Apps for Venture
and Interoperability
and Automation.
And I'll start
by saying that,
you know, One
Graph to Bind Them
All is a bit of clickbait,
and I hope it brought you to
this meeting, and
created some,
curiosity. But I
wanna, you know,
set the record straight.
I am I'm not here
to talk about
a new form of,
centralized monolith.
I'm not here to
tell you to burn
down your, your
legacy systems.
What I I am here,
to do is to propose the graph
is actually an ideal way to
coordinate end to end,
processes in
a distributed system
in a way that traditional
middleware and
even cloud native
tools are not capable.
So let's start.
So the problem statement we're
going to address
today might be
a little bit
different than some
of the other talks at CDW.
We're gonna focus today on
business operations.
And I think it's fair
to say that today,
in the world that's
increasingly,
you know, dynamic,
distributed,
and diverse,
business operations
are increasingly fragmented.
It's difficult
for businesses,
organizations to coordinate
across business
silos, cloud hosts,
and ecosystem partners.
I don't think these are news
flashes for anybody.
I think this is
a general experience.
And, again, graphs are well
suited for describing complex
real world relationships.
I think everyone
at CDW already
recognizes that,
but their use has
been generally
limited in visualization,
analysis,
and interoperability of data.
What we're gonna explore is
the use of graphs
to integrate data,
applications, services,
cloud hosts,
networks, and
physical devices.
Essentially, not just look at
data and properties, look at,
data and functions.
To look at, data
and behaviors.
So we're going to
look at building
information systems
using graphs,
entirely on graphs.
So my company,
company's no code platform,
essentially makes it easy for
customers to rapidly
model complex
distributed
operational domains
as a graph knowledge
base an enterprise
web. The scope is a bit bigger
than what you
might think of as
a an a data fabric or a data
mesh or virtualization
of data,
you many of you are gonna be
familiar with. Here,
we're talking
about an umbrella
abstraction that
provides a unified
interface for
weaving distributed
data and functions
to a logical
view with aggregated
system wide
entities, the index catalog of
type domain objects.
So a a broader scope,
a a complete scope actually,
allows us to take use data,
to use graphs,
data and functions to generate
highly contextual,
processes and services.
So my thesis is
that businesses
need an enterprise web,
a single source
of truth across
a complex distributed system.
And what we're talking about
here is a graph that helps
organizations bring order to
increasingly fragmented
operations,
higher level model,
higher level abstraction.
And this way they
can share leverage,
leverage shared metadata,
relationships,
and state to not
just drive human and
system discovery,
but also declarative
composition,
intelligent orchestration,
closed loop automation,
and policy based management.
So just think
about how powerful
a system would be
if you actually
had one pool of metadata and
relationships
implemented in a cloud
native way that's
fully distributable.
So it's not, you
know, centralized.
It's not monolithic.
It's fully distributable.
And then you can actually have
common pools of metadata and
relationships and
state information,
to manage your operations.
It would allow you
to personalize
customer experiences.
It would allow you to
synchronize your,
operations and optimize your
business transactions.
So at the heart of enterprise
web is our patented language.
It's called
the Graph Object in
Action Language or BOAL,
and it is a common machine
readable language for non
normalizing
heterogeneous solution
elements. And this is sort of
the fundamental
problem of the twenty
first century, at least it's
the software. But actually,
since software is
eating the world
and everybody wants
to be a digital
business, it really applies to
almost everyone.
Is how do they connect their
disparate systems,
their disparate
and distributed
systems that are also changing
very rapidly, evolving
very rapidly?
How How do they manage?
How do they work across that?
How do they connect
across silos?
ecosystem partners?
How do they work
across clouds?
How do you how do
you work across
this very fragmented
environment where,
you know, different endpoints
are using different protocols
and different formats and
different schemas?
And the answer really is high
level abstraction.
The user lies above this.
So our language
provides a graph
data structure
mapping properties,
behaviors, dependencies,
and constraints to a of of,
solution elements to a graph
knowledge base.
So we're talking about a very
rich graph, beyond
data types,
it's also functional types,
which makes our language goal
more than just, you know,
a modeling tool,
a domain modeling capability.
It's a domain
language, a DSL.
It's also also
gonna be modeling
interfaces, so we can manage
interoperability.
Configuration
language, so we
can, you know,
connect and configure,
distributed,
applications. And a workflow
language so that
we can actually
use graphs to
actually describe
sets of tasks that
are very dynamic,
that they they have
relationships,
and they bind on
bind on events
and policies. So we're talking
about a single language
that's a DSL,
an IDL, a CDL,
and a WDL in one.
My picture there
is blocking that.
So this is the conceptual
architecture of
Enterprise Web.
We start with
an upper ontology
of system concepts. Right?
And then enterprise
web presents,
customers with
a baseline model
that already
understands, you know,
generic enterprise
concepts and,
IT and cloud type
or system types.
And so we we give that to
everybody out of
the box. Right?
We understand what people are
and units are and
facilities and
locations and
various aspects of,
typical, enterprise
operation.
We also, of course,
understand,
you know, what,
protocols are,
formats are, types are,
so that we can manage
those as well.
Then we have an ability for
customers to model their own
domain as a graph
knowledge base.
And, here what we're talking
about is a knowledge base that
not just describes
their environment,
but connects it to this higher
level upper ontology,
which includes the types that
so they can actually generate
implementations out of them.
It can generate full blown
interfaces out of them.
It can actually,
connect processes,
can, you know,
expose services
using this system.
So now we're talking
about a graph
knowledge base to
model the domain
connected to a rich system
description of,
distributed systems.
And then at the bottom of this
is a catalog of objects,
the objects of
the domain. Right?
So you model your domain and
then you have objects
of your domain.
These are actually
the solution
elements that are relevant to
a particular customer.
It might be applications,
artifacts,
systems, services,
databases, devices.
It doesn't really
matter what they are.
It's the things that that is
that matter to that business
that they need to connect.
And we create make
it easier for
them to do that as well.
So we're talking
about a single
a a graph approach
to all three
layers upper ontology to graph
knowledge base,
to also describing objects as
so she abstract
data types as,
as, objects with
relationships,
concepts, types,
and policies,
which essentially
map them back
up to the domain,
then in turn up to
the, upper ontology.
So but having
a single language
means that this
could be highly
efficient because at
the end of the day,
an object is
a solution element
that's mapped to graph
knowledge base,
which is also a graph,
which is also match mapped up
to the upper ontology,
which is also a graph,
which means that
the whole thing
is just a function of
graph processing,
and we essentially have one
approach to graph processing
the whole thing.
That means we can
do very efficient,
real time,
contextual processes where it
might be much
more difficult to
do that given the latency with
cloud native toolchains,
which are middleware stacks.
So to get into that
a little bit deeper,
for modeling
the operational domain,
first I said, we
give you a baseline
model out of the box.
It includes generic device
concepts and types.
It's fully inspectable
and extensible.
Then customers can actually
start by they can jump start
their modeling by
importing a model,
like an XML, RDF,
JSON, etcetera.
They can even give
us pseudo UML
that might be in
a Word document
or a PDF document.
And we can import
those through
algorithmic entity
extraction,
and map those to
concepts in our
upper ontology to essentially
see the graph knowledge base.
And we do that in seconds.
And, from there,
solution architects
can continue
by manually curating the graph
knowledge base, right?
They can tune it,
they can extend it,
they can modify it as need be
for their operational domain.
And another way to get model
information into the system is
actually by
onboarding solution
elements themselves because as
you onboard more elements and
as your as your
use cases expand,
you're effectively going to be
expanding your
domain as well.
Right? So that
leads to this row
as you go concept.
Because everything
is done in graphs.
Graphs are optimally situated
not only for flexibly modeling
relationships, but, you know,
with graph, we all know that
graphs can actually
be modified
much more easily.
Static hierarchical
models, right,
they're easier to
evolve over time.
In enterprise web,
everything also happens
to be immutable,
so we version
control everything.
We're actually
version controlling
the the objects
in the catalog.
Version controlling the graph
knowledge base.
We're also version controlling
the upper ontology
as we put out
new releases. So everything is
version controlled.
Everything has audit history.
And this all allows you to
essentially model the use,
start with maybe
a narrow use case,
implement that, and
as you succeed,
expand the use case,
add more use cases,
and evolve with your, domain.
These are all
challenges in a hard
coded world that I think,
many of you probably
recognize.
So, as we when
we talk a little
bit deeper into object
modeling itself,
now we're actually
talking about
how we onboard
a singular, you know,
it's an application,
maybe it's a service,
maybe we wanna onboard.
What we actually
already have,
we give customers a catalog of
a couple hundred existing,
objects like
mappings to Amazon
cloud or Google
cloud, etcetera.
We have mappings for
a lot of common,
you know, cloud
native tools and,
etcetera, Kafka, MariaDB,
other things like that all out
of the box. But, you know,
customers can also
model their own,
their own solution elements.
And essentially what they're
going to do is
whether it's a code
package, it could
be an application,
a function, an algorithm,
or it could be a third party
orchestrator,
a controller, a system,
a database. We can
model adapters
using enterprise web.
Or if it's an endpoint
like an actual
service, that somebody
wants to model.
All of those can be modeled in
enterprise web.
Essentially, they're going to
become typed objects,
and the method is
effectively the same.
Essentially, there's
an interactive
API or a dynamic form.
When you're looking to onboard
something,
the system essentially
gonna present you
with cyclically,
either a UI driven wizard or
interactive API that's gonna
look for you to
enter information
that's gonna essentially
progressively type
the, object,
the solution
element that you're
looking to onboard.
And as you do that,
the system's gonna be,
in it's the type system that's
gonna be interacting
with the graph
knowledge base in the upper
ontology to
autofill properties
and behaviors that the system
already knows Because
the presumption
is the graph knowledge
base is in place,
the graph knowledge
is already in place.
So we already know a lot of
things about this domain.
So we know a lot
of things about
different kinds of types.
So we can auto fill
the properties
and generate very
rich interfaces.
So taking, thing
things that might,
onboarding things that
might have taken,
you know, days or weeks.
We can, you know,
even really complex things,
and we can do it
in in its towers.
So we're really
trying to simplify
the modeling
exercise itself at
the graph knowledge base level
as well as the onboarding
level as well.
Everything, like I said,
is persisted in
a backing store.
It's an immutable log style
append only storage.
It's cloud native
in its nature.
Right? All the objects in
Enterprise Web are
dynamically indexed,
tagged in version control.
So all those things
are just done as,
in the background
for the customers.
You don't have to worry about
those concepts.
Essentially, we're,
abstracting storage
from them.
So, we're also
providing a process
that facilitates updates and
upgrades because
all the objects
that you onboard,
all the solution elements that
you onboard are
gonna be version
control, can anticipate that
they're gonna change over time
as different partners
and vendors,
etcetera, update their service
endpoints or their
application code or,
or you update a technology
somewhere or change
a protocol.
When it's time
to update that,
you just go back
to that object,
you update it, the version
controlling it
will take the new
information,
we'll put that new
information, and
yet we'll also
preserve the history
so that we
know all changes
to that object
is the time and who
made those changes.
So this is what Enterprise Web
looks like as
a platform. Right?
So we take that architecture,
which I thought would be most
familiar to many of you given
interest in the type of people
who attend a CDW meeting.
So we focused on
the graph architecture,
but essentially we're wrapping
that with the capabilities of
an information system, right?
There's, you know,
object modeling as
I just described.
This is a design
environment for
declarative composition.
So once we have objects,
go to the catalog to carefully
compose objects
into, services,
and then we can chain services
into event driven processes,
all with no code. Right?
We're using
the metadata and the,
relationships, domain
semantics as well,
from the graph knowledge base
and the upper ontology, to,
compose all of these things so
that we can do them
with no code.
And of course, the system also
offers a runtime. Right?
It's a cloud native,
asynchronous,
concurrent, so it's
massively parallel,
event driven system.
It's reliable messaging,
transaction guarantees,
and state management all again
included just like we abstract
the storage we're actually
extracting a lot
of the complexity
of being cloud native
itself. Right?
And this is a real struggle,
even for advanced engineers.
They're largely doing these
implementing these ideas like
reliable messaging,
transaction guarantees,
state management
on a per solution
basis. And here
we're providing
it on a platform basis.
So it's available,
you know, just as,
that's something
that everybody
can rely on in
the background.
We're also wrapping it with
platform services.
Essentially we're replacing if
you look at this and you'll,
see a lot of common
terms here,
things that you
would expect in
a common middleware stack.
We're essentially replacing
the middleware
stack with a set
of serverless
patterns. Right?
Serverless middleware.
That's what this really is.
Instead of having
different components,
each have to
implement and then
manually integrate,
and then then you
have to write
your code your
applications to the top.
Here, enterprise web says,
you know what? Actually, no.
Model everything
declaratively,
and then either
the type system
will attach behavior
should background,
or, depending on
the use case,
you might need to
specify a certain
behavior, and you
then can call
these functions directly.
But what you're
getting is this
very lightweight,
low latency,
high performance middleware
that's all served
up in a cloud
native cloud.
So, this is, you know,
our enterprise web platform is
served at of fifteen
awarded patents,
and is deployed around
the world with,
you know, multiple variety of
industries from
telecom to life
sciences. Now I'm gonna go to
a concrete use case.
It's an SAP use case.
It's the SAP is the world's
largest enterprise
software company,
so I'm sure many of you are
familiar familiar
with them or,
if not, directly experienced
with working for SAP.
And, of course,
they have great products,
but like with any
large company
offering a wide
variety of solutions,
whether that's Salesforce
or Oracle or,
or Amazon or Google,
for that matter,
it's not always easy to work
across all of these. Right?
It's, they weren't
all architected
together. They have discrete
sets of tools and products.
And, you know, often today,
we're not just connecting,
one vendor's products
and services.
We're actually
connecting them with,
SAP and non SAP enterprise.
So this use case is
gonna explore that.
So, SAP customers
nowadays, like I said,
have to struggle
when confronted
with an increasingly complex
array of SAP and
non SAP endpoints.
So they need to
integrate, orchestrate,
manage, and maintain
across a set
of them.
Now SAP has a lot
of great assets,
a lot of great
development assets,
right? They have this,
thing called the Graph API,
which is the One Domain Model
with virtual data model.
They have these
TIG files called
the IMG SCRO.
They've got a lot
of great assets that
we can leverage,
but in and of themselves,
those assets aren't
fully connected.
Right? They lack the semantics
to fully connect a solution in
the kind of way
that I'm describing
to you. And solution delivery
over SAP at this time still
requires a mix
of custom code,
manual integration,
BPMN workflow modeling,
interface development,
and complex
configurations that
are gonna be done
with a mix of
model and code.
And, of course,
the problem is is once you've
done a mix of model and code,
the model's not
driving everything,
and that means
that you're gonna
have these black
holes where you
don't know where
things break,
and you're not gonna have end
to end transparency.
Distributed systems,
you really want that.
You wanna know where
things go wrong.
You wanna know
how your services
are being consumed. Right?
You wanna be able to analyze
that for security.
You wanna analyze that
for optimization.
You want to make
sure that your
customer is having great,
experiences and that you're
supporting your SLAs.
So transparency
is non trivial.
So, let's look at
a service, right?
This is sort of a, you know,
in the process world,
they would call
something like this,
like a three byte
kebab or a five
byte kebab, which
is the industry
kind of jargon or
describing a simplistic
process. But, you know,
there's gonna be a third party
customer portal
where somebody's
gonna order a cloud
application.
Right? So this is
gonna be a a a
cloud native or
a digital business
use case. Somebody's gonna
actually order something that
is in effect,
a digital product,
a cloud application,
And the delivery
will also then
be a system delivery. Right?
It's gonna be
it's not it's not
selling jeans or a car.
We're selling
something that's,
completely, like,
visual end to end.
So and then delivery
is gonna be done,
over, Google in this case.
And so we're gonna
have a third
party product,
and a third party
delivery system, but the,
ERP type services in between
will all be SAP.
So what we want
is some sort of
model connect across those,
because without that model,
we're gonna be doing manually
integrating, and that's all we
have to do. And
especially since,
you know, these
aren't all fully
connected even
the SAP products
aren't fully
connected by a model
and let alone
connecting across
the others. So instead
of, you know,
writing interfaces,
doing manual integration,
doing manual code,
and then, of course,
maintaining all
that coding and
recoding, integrating and
reintegrating as
things change,
because if any one of these
elements change,
your solution grows.
We're gonna do this
all in a model.
with Enterprise Web.
So here now you see Enterprise
Web over the top.
It's providing the abstraction
layer I described,
the middleware
services, right,
called the platform services,
and the cloud native
platform runtime.
So we're not it's not gonna
happen magically, right,
we're gonna leverage those SAP
developer assets
to begin with,
right? So we're
gonna take those
assets that I told
you that were
disconnected, and we're gonna
connect them.
We're gonna create
one unified graph SAP domain,
and we're gonna do
it in minutes,
and, we're gonna then
show it to you.
And, we're gonna so we're we
don't have to throw
away assets.
That would be silly.
We wanna leverage
those assets,
because they're good,
so it it streamlines
and accelerates
our solution delivery.
So we'd be fools not to,
leverage the existing,
documentation and models,
that partners provide.
So in this case, you know,
an architecture architect can
call these APIs,
call this documentation,
they're going to import them
into the system,
the system is going
to do the entity
extraction, and
it's essentially
going to set up
that that initial,
graph knowledge base, right?
It's gonna set up your,
graph operational domain.
It's gonna generate
generate a unified
graph connected
SAP domain model
mapped to our upper ontology
just as I described.
And by that mapping
of the SAP domain,
which by itself wouldn't be
connected to
the enterprise web
of ontology,
where it's getting
it's being wrapped essentially
in additional
concepts, types,
and policies, which
enable the declarative
composition and
the intelligent
orchestration.
From there, with,
now that we've
onboarded the models,
we're gonna onboard
these objects.
Right? We're gonna
onboard these,
domain objects,
which is the service
themselves.
Now at some level already,
since we have Graph
Knowledge Base,
and we import when we imported
the SAP assets,
we learned about
their objects,
their interfaces,
their properties,
and behaviors. We're already
gonna be able to
generate a lot
of this information
here as far
as these three services
are concerned.
So even a lot of that work is
gonna be done.
We're even gonna
generate, configs and
things, for these,
out of the documentation that
was provided by SAP.
So, again, we're
always seeking
to leverage things that exist
so that we can
accelerate solution
delivery and that
put people in
this sort of very agile graph
domain model.
And the last step,
in this case was
because we also
talked about processes.
Now, we could
model from scratch
an enterprise web a process.
It's essentially
an enterprise web.
Processes are data flows.
A data flow is, by
the way, is a graph.
Right? It's a natural
graph. Right?
An enterprise web, a process,
the definition of a process is
a set of tasks
with relationships
to events and policies.
So there are
the tasks then bind.
It's not a static flowchart.
This the tasks bind
based on conditions,
which is very exciting.
It allows you to
have, really,
creative, policy
based, process,
processes, event
driven processes
that can respond to
a lot of variance,
a lot of what you
would call in
a traditional flowchart
exception paths,
which become very
difficult to maintain,
will make that much easier.
In this case,
actually, though,
we're just going to import SAP
actually had a log,
called Action Logs.
We're going to import
the Action Log,
extract the logic,
and map it back
up to the objects
in the model,
generate an event
driven data flow process with
all the service integration
points and
the corresponding UIs
completed out of the box on
import within seconds.
Again, leveraging assets to
great effect to accelerate
solution delivery.
If you do everything manually
into enterprise web,
but where you have assets,
leverage them.
The point here
at at its core,
enterprise web is a no code
integration
automation platform.
It's completely
open for federation
and extension,
so we're creating
this environment
so that you can
onboard whatever you need to
onboard into the domain as you
describe it, and we're just
trying to make it easy for you
to have that
domain and use and
share that metadata.
So, we're gonna
go to I'm gonna
pass the baton
here into a demo.
And in a second,
my colleague,
Bill, is a chief
assistant architect.
He's gonna provide the demo.
He's gonna do that
use case that
I just described.
He's essentially gonna walk it
backwards. He's gonna show you
the process that
we generated.
He's gonna run the process,
which will be a mix
of system steps.
And he's gonna drill
into the process
tasks, and he's gonna show you
how it was connected
by metadata.
You're gonna see the objects
being referenced.
He's Just gonna click
into an object.
You're gonna see all
of that metadata.
You're gonna see how the meta
that object is mapped up to
the knowledge base,
to the SAP domain.
You're gonna see how the SAP
domain is actually
mapped up to
the upper ontology,
and you're gonna be literally
be able to walk that
graph seamlessly.
If you and if you
have the right
permissions, you could just do
that as Bill Kent will do that
in the demo. So
I hope you enjoy
the demo. I hope you
enjoy the presentation
. Thank you very much,
and have a great